- [Narrator] Oh, the seashore.
The waves, the water, the seaweed,
the sheep?
Are they eating seaweed?
(sheep bleating)
We've gotta figure this out.
(mid-tempo music)
So, here's a little context
to start off the story.
We're on an island, high,
high, high up in Scotland,
called North Ronaldsay.
It's so remote you can only
get here by ferry or airplane.
And on this small, picturesque island,
home to only 50 people,
lives a very, very rare breed
of sheep: the seaweed sheep.
Meet Kevin, the authority
on all-things seaweed sheep.
- [Narrator] So let's learn
more about this rare species.
Welcome to Seaweed Sheep 101.
(sheep bleats)
- [Narrator] They are smaller
than the average sheep,
and their wool can be
black, white, gray or brown.
The males have big, curly horns.
And so do some females, and ...
(light music)
- [Narrator] As a result,
the sheep were confined
to the seashore and were
forced to survive on seaweed.
This changed their
digestive system over time,
making them one of only
two animals in the world
who are able to survive on seaweed alone.
And this wall, known as the sheep dyke,
makes sure they stay on
the shore. Right, Kevin?
- [Narrator] Oh, OK, well,
Heather, over to you.
- Behind me is the native sheep dyke.
This was constructed in 1832.
The North Ronaldsay
sheep dyke is essential
in the genetic structure of the sheep.
North Ronaldsay sheep have
a very high intolerance
to copper, so they die from over-nutrition
by grazing on the grass for too long.
So we keep them on the
shore, and they eat seaweed,
which has got very low
levels of iodine and copper.
(sheep bleating)
(soft music)
(electronic music)